hi I'm Mohammed I am the narrative lead
on apex legends and I'm Griffin Brennan
Dean I'm a game designer on apex legends
and today we'll be talking about each
and every legend and apex legends
[Music]
new season let's go
our first new character drop his name is
octane Octavio Sylva Octane's main thing
is speed we're bringing back stim yep
and we really liked the idea of the
people running the gauntlet in titanfall
2 and putting up the YouTube videos and
the way they did it was by launching
themselves with a grenade blast so
Octane's back story is that he blew off
his legs with a grenade blast trying to
beat the world record at the gauntlet
and now he's got these like Brin new
Robo away Robo legs basically be able to
run fast yeah and he uses stem he is a
hundred percent about the adrenaline
rush yeah more than anything else he
feels like someone who's involved in
extreme sports yeah yeah it's he's much
like yeah he's yeah an extreme ass he's
an extreme athlete yeah yeah you go
really fast when you use the stem
ability he inflicts a little bit of
health damage to him himself but his
passive is is that he regenerates health
over time at a slow he's got this he's a
little dialysis machine that's basically
filtering his blood very slowly
yes stim out of it his ultimate is a
jump pad that the whole squad can use
and you can bounce grenades off of it or
other character ability so you can use
it to launch yourself over enemy squads
you can use it to launch yourself upon
the ledges and stuff the way that you
use a pathfinder my personal favorite
thing is you can do things like bouncing
Gibraltar bubble dome off of the thing
and wherever it lands you follow you can
you can then it will deploy and you can
follow it you can bounce jump pads off
of jump pads and create chains of jump
pads real men use iron sights I use
unlike previous characters that like
I've helped right it was a strong black
woman yeah yeah I remember one of our
audio guys told me like you know his
sister was a Marine mm-hmm and like
their whole family came from this like
very very proud know just like military
that's yeah yeah you know Bangalore
comes from like you know a strong
military back exactly she's actually ex
IMC which I know is often considered
like the bad guys of the titanfall
you know yeah but not from her point of
view from her point of view she has like
you know yeah a very proud military
history and I like that yeah she's
definitely a good guy so my senior right
at the time hated Bangalore cuz you guys
wanted basically like a easy for
beginners to understand like yeah so it
was it was trying to solve a couple
problems it was a trying to make a sort
of meeting potatoes straightforward
soldier character it was trying to solve
the a major offensive problem we had in
our maps which is how do I advance a
squad against a defensive position over
a large swath of open ground where it's
like before Bangalore you can charge but
you're just gonna get hoes a lot of
people ask where the name Bangalore came
from there were two things that was
influencing it one is the Bangalore
torpedo and it found service clearing
defensive structures like the barbed
wire on the beaches of Normandy the
whole mechanical set for Bangalore came
from the Punjab soldiers that served in
the Indian arm of the British military
during World War one those soldiers had
to cross massive swaths of no-man's land
and stuff and so smoke and the type of
bombardment that Bangalore employs is
what's called a creeping barrage and so
that's a barrage that you synchronized
with a group of infantrymen where it
lands about fifty to a hundred yards out
basically your team needs to like move
with it exactly exactly I'm personally
proud of what the team has accomplished
in terms of the characters is that I
feel like mechanically writing-wise
animation wise in terms of voice acting
you're not just playing a mechanical set
that has a personality you're you're you
are that character right that
combination of the the determined tone
and you're not going to knock me over
I'm gonna knock you over when you get
shot at you don't get hit but when
you're taking fire and you're running
you double time you you move faster we
implemented that to give people
confidence to just close with people and
you can be under with
fire and just keep pushing no matter
what you know the smoke launcher allows
you to Vance your squad and you can use
that in a defensive role and offensive
boats highly flexible it deals damage
and so the hit numbers can tell you how
many occupants of a building there are
and then of course there's the
bombardment but like to me the whole
thing ended up being very powerful as an
entirety as well because it ended up
being like an homage to african-american
regiments like the Harlem Hellfighters
to fight during World War one right that
actually was one of my favorites
actually the important thing to take
away with bloodhound is that bloodhound
is a character that is designed all
around starting and entering fights from
as best a tactical perspective as
possible in that you have information
about where enemies have been what
they've done
the ultimate allows you to see through a
lot of sort of defensive off you station
smoke castle and stuff and track people
better so if someone's trying to flee
from a bloodhound it's just not it's not
gonna happen
yeah like if you're wounded and crawling
away from a bloodhound that's unless
someone's covering you it's just not
gonna work I'm sorry you just kind of
died at that point the character doesn't
inherently have any defensive abilities
the idea is if you understand what your
enemy is capable of your enemy's
position and you have more information
about your enemy than they have about
you you can make decisions and control
when the fight happens where it happens
and if you make all of those things
favorable to you you win and if you know
you're being followed by a bloodhound
you can actually use the fact that the
bloodhound can follow you reliably to
bait them into traps to ambush them as
we go through all the care so we'll talk
about this but a lot of them are sort of
designed in a sort of an ecosystem where
they're meant to have strengths and
limitations so that they're sort of
inter reliant as a fighting unit and I
think that's what makes sort of that
baseline squad play interesting it's not
any hard counters day yes and also you
have three members and there are four
roles so we have our offense defense
recon and support characters and so
there's four roles but you're always
lacking one role in the squad which
means that you have to supplement that
deficit with teamwork or strategy the
squad is always going to have some
weakness in some area I think that
he's been very accurate with the
bloodhound Bangalore combo
yes so they're both a very powerful
assault unit and that the bloodhound can
say this is where the enemies are and
then the Bangalore can focus on the AVI
station of the smoke with the pulse and
ultimate yeah it is the other one sees
through yes if you are playing Bengal or
you always want to listen for bloodhound
audio cues because if you hear a
bloodhound that is not your bloodhound
do the the combat screen you know you
don't want to put the smoke yeah yeah so
the tracking ability one of the big
things that we had a problem with was
originally it was not tied to mobility
stuff so things like mantling running
all its up didn't generate evidence
markers it was only things like gunshots
blood fighting isn't a moving thing it's
more kind of like a puddle so you just
got this big clustering you're like yeah
there's death box --is and people fought
here you telling me what I already know
so adding the mobility element to that
really helped so that it was much more
of a you get more bread comp breadcrumb
trails across the map blood on was a
tough one I based it the character's
personality off of an amalgamation of
one of my favorite Viking characters and
a couple of my close personal friends
one of them's non-binary and the other
one is gender fluid they had a big
impact on me and I realized I would
really like to have a character that
represented a non-binary person to me I
knew from the beginning because I was
making a non-binary character that I
wanted them to have an androgynous voice
because I wanted anyone to be able to
feel like they can put themselves into
that role it's super important to the
whole company to have you know inclusion
and diversity and representation the
people who make these games us included
the people who play these games they
come from all walks of life and like the
world is diverse there's so many
cultures and so many things that that
people haven't seen before in their
daily lives or that they might not be
familiar with definitely not that like
we hit everything I know but we're
trying it's a process it's a process
this is my favorite part bass man yes
you boy is the Internet so originally
when we wrote caustic we wrote as a feel
right and I'm Gloria I'm gassing people
I don't feel like I'm the good guy
the original fantasy from a mechanical
standpoint was sort of the monster in
the fog you can't see very well you
can't breathe very well you can just
hear this ventilator coming through the
gas and you don't know where he is but
he's getting closer and it's sort of
like it was sort of like our games
version of the hatch and dragon horror
movie when the first pitch to make him
sympathetic came through I remember
bringing up the actual guy who invented
mustard gas in World War one that nature
of warfare is such a inhumane method of
conducting warfare that I think it's
weird to say I'm glad that cost that
came to embody that the good guy good
guy gas man it wasn't working all right
let's take this back the drawing board
and I remember had that conversation
with you and I was like all right well
let's turn it to a sociopath very
pragmatic like human life means less
than science kind of attitude yes yeah
one of the hardest things to bring this
character life on it sounds weird but
the head - there's a version where he
looked like a pyro from tf2 and that was
super old and then there was a man
constantly referred to him as being a
caustic because he looked like a
beekeeper like just a big yellow
beekeeper and he couldn't move his neck
it wasn't like if he was sideways you
basically couldn't see his face at all
yeah he was like you couldn't tell he
was looking at you to fire at you we
kept it all the time we try to work with
it but animation was having one hell of
a time with it and eventually we ended
up going with the goggles gas masks
crazy hair beard and like as soon as we
saw that kind of like okay yes that's
clearly awesome the biggest debate that
we sort of had with him more or less is
the gas affecting teammates in some of
our previous projects we've had team
colored abilities and all this stuff
where you know this would be this color
if it was good in this color this would
be this color if it was bad also from a
simplicity standpoint we tried to make
it that all caustics are immune to all
cost the gas everyone else is affected
we didn't want we don't want team damage
because that that's not just a team game
yeah team is damaged yeah they have to
stay away from you in all games
including badder aliens and ours too
there's there's a lot of just learning
that you
yeah like for example yeah the cost of
gas tanks not a lot of people notice but
if you shoot the bass they're figuring
it out yeah but in general we don't like
secret knowledge and that was like one
of those is like how do I learn this
which gas is like the one that doesn't
hurt me for some guys yeah I think it
was just easier to be like okay well I
know if I go to this guy's it's going to
affect me yeah the hole yeah but he
plays the game constantly every single
day that four o'clock we play the game
whatever the latest you know working
build is yes like that's really the key
to like you know character balance and
also likability yes
finding out what characters like their
personalities like classic yeah if we
never played him I would have never
found out that that personality no
matter how well written yeah didn't
match the character yeah yeah I know
yeah animation once we were like yeah
it's the monster in the closet the smoke
the animation ran with it well they they
like they went hand with like on the
glad I could like him holding up
lifelines drone like this like he's good
he's like it's like he's like giving
somebody like a bag lunch almost like
he's like I brought this for you like
the first probably went through the most
visual changes art style was very
military titanfall - yeah look and like
he's definitely kept a lot of like yeah
just like with the packs on him and
everything you know once we decided we
were making a character game and we
wanted to like branch out into like more
interesting characters than just
military characters I named him
Gibraltar and I fought for cousin for a
while nobody thought that the name
Gibraltar was like nobody will be able
to remember that name but I pushed for
it and I feel like Manny may have made
him Polynesian initially because of the
Rock of Gibraltar I think it may have
been a Dwayne the rock Johnson reference
right for a while there was talk of him
being Maori there was talk of him being
Samoan and then we sort of decided that
we wanted to sort of cover as many of
sort of the Pacific Islands as possible
in and of itself I think it's its own
cultural continent that's not widely
represented in many games and so I think
bringing it to this was just yeah we
don't just want to be an accent or
that's a thing I like things you don't
want it to be
yeah yeah and so things like the potty
or married club that the Jade or
whalebone war club we sort of talked
about things like the haka and the
significance because it's such a I think
important part of those cultures and
those warrior traditions and all of
those things Gibraltar is a warrior in a
lot of ways Edd's
you know speaking to matching you know
personality to gameplay so that
character is definitely a shield for the
team yes like very protective of the
team and then like so when my writer
Manny went out to write um he created
this whole backstory about saris which
is the search search and rescue yeah
search and rescue Association of solace
which sauce is a planet his parents like
grubs like basically saving people and
when him and his boyfriend got into a
motorcycle accident his dad lost his arm
yeah to save him and that really touched
them so when he grew up you know what I
mean that like stuck with him and like
maybe even created a motto for this
imaginary yeah search and rescue
organization which is the shield to
protect those in need yes and that very
much so matches gibraltars personality
right like warrior he's a fighter yeah
but first and foremost personally
protecting is a protector yeah likes
protecting people Yeah right over the
course of the characters development
like a lot of people drew parallels
between
Bangalore's bombardment and your
Baltar's bombardment but I do feel like
in the final shipping game they fill two
fundamentally different roles because
it's mental working yeah with your with
your shields if you if you throw the
bombardment and then drop the thing you
can do a hammer hammer and anvil tactic
where you can basically create an
exclusion zone that pushes people away
and during that 15 seconds they either
have to basically step into the ring or
back off right yeah the character is a
character that tries to maintain
distance and spacing it's very important
for you to have like sniper battles
because of the shield you always like if
they fire and you fire at the same time
they're gonna hit your shield and break
your shield and you're gonna destroy
them yeah some people if you don't want
to push you wanna push it in actually so
Gibraltar encaustic are both defensive
care yes but as caustic wants you to
come in close to him yeah driver one
wants to keep you once they can you yeah
so the best way to play Gibraltar
actually is as a long-range defensive
yeah you play backfield and if you you
know if something
is wrong you have tools for doing damage
control you can throw the bombardment
out and block a zone where people were
coming in you can cut people's retreats
off you could if you're in a building
you can drop it on the house like
watching people play classic lifeline
Gibraltar like people the caustic will
block all the doors yeah and lifeline
will heal and Gibraltar will peek
windows and if a squad gets too aggro
tries to push in like say the first
floor they're like oh this caustic gas
here and the Gibraltar is like and
there's also a bombardment outside so
either come in with us scream so like
it's very much gives you a lot of
flexibility for forcing people's hands
and as the meta evolves there's going to
be more room for tactical gameplay and
ability usage and basically forcing
people who may be better shots than you
into the batter's positions and
leveraging that sort of strategic high
level to win matches that you you
wouldn't be able to win in a heads-up
gunfight I like lying a lot
who doesn't like well he doesn't like
life why not she's so spunky
the drone came on by and you know drove
in 101 on the drone and the drones like
her friend and I'm like I love this you
know lifeline having that thing to
emot-- with just made it so much easier
to kind of find the personality or the
mocap stage a lot of times we have an
idea when we go on to the mocap stage
and sometimes those ideas like come
through a hundred percent other times we
find the character oh yeah
the moment I remember very specifically
in lifelines development was actually
pretty late when the facial animations
came in because I feel like lifeline is
particularly expressive and the one that
I think of specifically is the legendary
where she spins the healing syringe like
a pistol and then catches it and there's
this sort of look of joy where she's
like almost surprised it's funny you
mentioned that good yeah so all of our
characters we model them with a very
blank expression right was yes for some
people like caustic it works
right you don't like you don't really
don't need a lot of facial animation to
see the evil but Anna character like
lifeline who's like voice is so like fun
and like having that dead face really
you're like with
like it's hard and like I remember like
the first time like you know life lines
face was animated yeah like I fell in
love with her I was like I'm so adorable
you don't see the whole thing come
together and tell very something like
though for me at least specifically
those facial animation can and even like
for a character that's that's so
light-hearted so like that some of the
executions are actually pretty dark yeah
my favorite one is still the dock shock
one with where she pulls a cable off the
drone and shocks the person they look on
her face when she turns and looks at the
drone she's like dude she's like yeah
just do it and it's so it's so
mischievous so it's amazing the core
mechanical set was to really sort of
make a combat medic like someone really
feel comfortable running out to help
teammates under fire like we don't just
want a healing character we want a
character that feels like they're
putting they're putting themselves at
risk to help their team one of the big
things we were trying to figure out with
lifeline from a general gameplay balance
standpoint for a long time was in a game
where your goal is not to die how do we
make sure that a character who is really
good at making you not die like doesn't
become the meta where things like damage
interrupts and stuff like that that make
it so that you can't use you can't use
the drone to heal through damage if
you're directly under fire and that's
the thing and so we had this there's an
interesting duality in the character of
some of the abilities you need to use
and cover and all that stuff but others
like the the rest you're suppose to use
just great in the middle of combat and
their bullets flying and all this stuff
probably on the same level as Wraith I
would say there's not many more
characters that you need to worry about
more than losing track of where a
lifeline went because as soon as you
lose track of the lifeline that means
she's gonna come back with like 10
billion health and like a bunch of you
know she's gonna be like she's gonna be
like finishing like trying to finish her
friends and you're gonna be run ragged
and she's gonna come back like I've
dusted myself off and I'm ready to fight
again and you're just like oh no I'm
tired and I want to go home and she's
like oh you're going home
I may have tricked you so in many ways
Mirage his personalities based off of me
bit smarmy that talks a little fast
there's a lot of fun though there's a
lot of fun Mirage was actually a bit
vague having hollow pilots of himself
and like having fun with them yeah and
like you know kind of like joking with
them and like you know just basically
loving himself a lot yeah very vain even
things like when he's in the menu and
you know he's going like this and then
there's the wingman his Hanako where did
that come from you know like and then he
like goes like this thing and it's gone
or like we're making that the bird
appear like there's a lot of like sort
of new old-timey vaudevillian stuff in
there that I really I did a little bit
milk at but mostly mocap was done by
Sean and he basically said I thought of
you and then I just exaggerated I'm like
I don't know how to take that this
battery is this weird fine line between
like you know this show that's like all
about like battle and fighting and
everything and then like mirage comes in
and he's just like I just want to look
good his solo lines with everybody else
on his squad is dead and I'm still
talking to myself yeah so he all the
characters have to say everything just
for game state stuff but he's dealing
with the comments that he's alone and
talking to himself
just a minute or in close and I'm
talking to myself fantastic people don't
often talk to themselves
yeah like caustic was a little bit easy
cuz you know he's a bit loony and it's
not too hard to imagine he likes to hear
his own voice yeah but most of the other
characters it's like okay how do I say
this without sounding weird cuz you're
talking to yourself like the rest of
your teammates are dead in you're
playing solo yeah Mirage was easy yeah I
was just like he just almost breaks the
fourth wall basically like this is kind
of silly you know what I mean I'm myself
but here I go yeah it's his character
yeah perfectly I think of all the
characters he probably has the most
attitude for anyone coming from
titanfall to who's familiar with the
hollow pilot things like when people see
they're like oh that's the hollow pilot
guy there's a little bit of they've got
their guard up but anybody who's coming
new into the
experience doesn't understand that
there's such a thing as a fake guy
running around right and so watching you
watch a clip of like a guy like Santa
halep I round a corner and like a
bloodhound it was like a cat with a
laser pointer where it just like leaps
off of a rock and like starts like
trying to like budget and it just like
disappears and they're like and then
like they're like like obliterated they
don't realize it's fake yes so it's
grated that's not gonna happen much
longer yeah there's the learning curve
like Raj is actually a great example of
how we we like to try and come up with
like a 1 or 2 or 3 word descriptor
character the trickster like the
magician who's like yeah bawd villian
like yeah he's basically putting on a
performance and like the hollow pilot
and his personality and everything just
so like yeah I just really feel that
character like really came together
really well
ya know it's it's awesome it was pretty
easy he's very much marvin 2.0 from
titanfall and we knew that all we had to
do was bring that character into this
game and give him a voice high-five the
community loved that the Marvin's these
poor little worker boss that had like
these like smiley faces and then moated
sad faces I'm like and have they never
got how I thought he'd never got yeah
the the faction leader in time fall to
the Marvin never got a high five yeah
like yeah half to make up yeah Marvin
yeah he has to get high five yeah and
like I force right so like one of the
first day animations and I mean very
first animations we ever did was
Pathfinder basically doing the grapple
into the forest high five kill and that
animation I'm pretty sure is what
spawned the idea of executions we
weren't even planning on having
executions in this because we didn't
know how to incorporate them in
titanfall too if you just went up behind
somebody immediately execute them yeah
but we were like well that's really
cheap in a battle royale we're not gonna
do that
Pathfinder is an interesting character
mechanically because Pathfinder gives
you access to terrain and ground that
you would not normally be able to fight
from and him making those superior
positions available is extremely
powerful so he gets read up
so you can very easily go like this is
where a pathfinder has been I see the
squad moving right now like they're not
going to do any kind of like crazy
wizard magic and he's got his mobility
so which helps him in direct fights but
a lot of his abilities focusing more on
positioning and getting your squad to
positions and selecting ground to fight
from more than the actual heavy lifting
like the way that Bengal or Gibraltar
does heavy combat lifting it's much more
sort of intro/outro
like you can get your squad out of a
really bad situation like you know Scout
what's up ahead yeah his ability is
passive ability of being able to see
where circles are down the road I think
as them the the meta of often the Metis
shifts having pairing him with
characters that want to know where the
circle is as early as possible is really
gonna become I think an important combo
because he's giving you two tactical
information and allowing you to get
ahead of more offensive squads and
prepare for basically the really
aggressive Wraith Bangalore bloodhound
squads and so I think there's a lot of
power in that package I love the concept
art that they did where he's a window
cleaning robot and he's got the mop and
in the reflection he's got the rocket
launcher and all the guys holding up the
signs we love you Pathfinder and I think
was Manny who was like he's just a robot
looking for purpose by participating in
the bloodsport it seems like Marvin's do
have a breaking point maybe in another
time of space
but not this one great hardest
characters yeah oh my god like when you
guys finalized on the design of its a
person who travels between two points in
space yeah goes into the void and she
hears voices in her head yeah I was like
oh like that so it was it was phase was
a very contentious point on this project
like we went through this character went
through probably more iteration than I
think any other character yeah we
restarted race three times when we were
first experimenting with the concept of
characters we were pulling abilities
from titanfall to the first thing that
we had in there was was titanfall to
phase shift
it was rough because titanfall to phase
shift there's no trail so you have a
person who disappears reappears at some
other random point in space and can
immediately just go guns up and and hose
you from a learnability center like what
do I do about this and the answer is
like well don't let wraiths you just
like run away or it's not valid yeah I
mean that's why you'd made it so that
like there's a significant delay yes
when she comes out of phase and the guns
up yes we want the character to be a
phase skirmisher so she's all about not
presenting a solid target for people and
not committed over committing to fights
Wraith loses when she over commits to a
fight she's much more about playing the
peripheries harassing from the side
harassing from the rear she's going to
use it to either make lateral movements
or cautiously aggressive movements where
she might use it to go from like here to
some cover up in front of her but she's
not going to go directly up into your
face pop into existence and then just
shotgun you like it and so if you lose
track of a wraith you should be
concerned wraith was the hardest
character for me to find the focus on
the voices in the head presented it like
a real problem because our game is a
sci-fi game it's not a fantasy take you
scary good right so it can't be like
spirits so I was watching Donnie Darko
actually and then it kind of like hit me
what if the void is a window into
infinite dimension you know she's doing
is stepping out of this dimension into
this void space that's a window into
every infinite other dimension and then
back in right now and then when she's in
that window she can somewhat see into
you know what I mean
like other possibilities it looks like
that in the void you see little ghost
images of wraiths that's basically
infinite versions of her from other
dimensions also passing through the void
at the same time and that's what the
voices are they're basically seeing
through a window and be warning you like
you see you you know brave receives
voices about whenever your sights are
being fired out whenever you're being
looked at grenades traps all this stuff
and the idea was is that the portal
allows you to move an entire squad and
when you first start using it feels
highly situational but the more that
you're comfortable you get with it the
more applications you have if you just
think of it as risking only one person
while moving three people as a value
proposition it becomes very useful and
wide range of scenarios the combination
of being able to hear when someone's
aiming at you and then being able to
phase out and place the portal the idea
was is that you can charge a sniper you
can charge a machine-gun physician
that's a thing if your squad is pinned
down and move everybody either up on the
position or around the flank or out of
harm's way and you can really pick your
fights in a lot of ways with Wraith and
from a mechanical standpoint she's
actually kind of an interestingly
selfless character in some ways in that
she's risking herself to save everybody
else because she's the only person who
isn't actually it can move forward and
is fully aware of all the consequences
of the situation it's funny bring up
using the ultimate and the tactical at
the same - yes because this was one of
the first characters are created and
that led to us changing our animation
systems most of the time we animate the
hands like in the first-person view
together and since design wanted to be
able to use you know the portal but at
the same time be able to activate the
tactical yeah we need to switch up our
animation system and it's a readability
thing for the player as well I can
always learn that like okay I'm using
the tactical now I'm using portal it
just helps reinforce you know like the
UI and everything else when everything
works together yeah
how you doing he's definitely an
aggressive flanker he's he i think he'll
pair well with wraith bangalore
bloodhound i think he's gonna sort of
fit into that heavy offensive mix he's
an offensive character but he's not
inherently a CQ character other than how
you equip him with weapons and stuff
like that so he's much more about
closing flanking running down for
fleeing squads like he's very his
ability to rotate and maneuver is like
the source of his his power and
introduce himself or extricate himself
from situations most squads because
movement speed is relatively fixed you
have to play within a certain distance
each other for a reasonable response
time he can move so quickly with his
ability cuz he can use stim basically
back-to-back so like he's sacrificing
health every time he does it which is
sort of part of that in the spirit of
sort of extreme sports pushing yourself
like running in the red line if you want
to play them conservatively because
you're too scared about the stim takes a
little bigger health away you could you
play them a little bit more defensively
yes yeah I don't stim into fights
actually I usually stay with my team in
two fights but if it's hairy I stem and
get the hell out of it but I've seen
people who like you know are pretty
confident in their shooting skills and
aren't worried about taking damage
basically you know stim back to back to
back to back to just like get in there
get the gun first you know you've got
the drop on people shoot shoot shoot and
to hide in a corner and heal up but yeah
super aggressive players aren't going to
love ya I think it's going to present a
real challenge to defensive players and
how yes deal with them but at the same
time if he gets too far ahead of his
team yeah I mean we'll see how the
medicine will talk cause I think it's
gonna introduce a lot of really exciting
stuff like we have an idea of what its
gonna do never know like so we're
playing with Octane's
abilities for probably about six months
but you just never know what happens
until you get it out there into the
hands of like millions of like pros
that's true yeah so for example like
Bangalore I never saw her defensive
smoke
I'll put smoke down his book down like
right in front of me and run off as like
that viable of a solution until it like
got out there and that's like
clearly a very valid place I know what I
expect with octane but I'm more excited
about what I what people do people do
yeah yeah
so that's all of our legends so far
we'll have more coming thank you so much
for playing our game thank you it's been
a surreal experience
we're hoping we had something good but
we really didn't know what we had until
so thank you thank you for supporting us
and yeah keep striving because we love
to watch
[Music]